the
island Portugal talks about a country with
sea there is talk about a country with fishermen with
a great fishing tradition And the
Portuguese conserves an excellent tradition that must
be kept promoting and here to
encourage
and
in Portugal the Century old Craft Karem
close still Going  strong I will have others in
Play Store at your Feet in the margins
between the turn downs for What is worth
Living Together another shan's fashion in
want to enter my name is Ricardo
Pereira
EA my profession is master fisherman
every day a challenge we usually
leave around 22  23
hours irrigation at more or less those
11 at times noon the next day the
cold water of the North Atlantic has
properties that make sardines
have the unique characteristics and
we most likely have the best
straight in the world and I call  António
Pinhão I have been working at this factory here for 37
years
the founder of this factory was my grandfather
and my uncle Manoel pinhão is that the
workers of this factory  family
here we have always kept the same
traditional process since 1920
in the whole process is handmade we are the
only factory in Portugal I used this
process when the syringe well they
all go strong then when Cidinha goes
to cook then some space time in which
the  employee then the condiments
then passes everything to the call to
launch by putting the sardine in the can
there are only three machines that are for cooking the
fish to record the fish customize the
profile and this time it takes to make
a can all these phases I give
a kiss today was
the best I have no doubt it
's better
and
the store of preserves in porto is
downtown in the historic center of porto we
sell here about 20 different
species of portuguese fish
most representative sardines then
tuna
and we have  Here Factory that manufactures
centenarians I have already thought about the importance of
doing this here is in fact to have
a lot of what is good tradition
conserved  Portuguese lady we are taking
back an inhabitant of a betrayal
and to think that this tradition that has been
in my family for four generations
represents a lot of the history of this country
for me can only be proud of this
whole traditional process all working
with hands not using  machines This
is synonymous with quality I feel
very bad inside this
Andthere
[Music]